another
non-philosopher that may be considered a
philosopher
since we're talking about reality is ayn
rand and
her philosophy of objectivism
what are your thoughts on her sense
of taking this idea of reality
calling her philosophy objectivism and
uh
kind of starting at the idea that
you really could know everything and
it's pretty obvious
and then from that you can derive an
ethics about how to live life
like what is the what is the good
ethical life and all
the virtue of selfishness all that kind
of stuff uh
so you talked to a lot of academic
philosophers so i'd be curious to see
from the perspective of like
is she somebody that's uh
taken seriously at all uh
why she dismissed as i see from my
distant perspective
by serious philosophers and also like
your own personal thoughts of like is
there some interesting bits
that you find uh inspiring in her work
or not okay so i'm rand
i've had so many exceedingly intelligent
students basically
give me her books and basically say
please
dr basulka read this book and i'll tell
them
yes thank you i've read this book before
and then want to engage in
you know let me put it this way they're
religious about
ein rand okay so to them ayn rand
represents some type
of way of life right her objectivism
um now why is she not taken seriously
by philosophers in general well let me
put it this way
um philosophers in general tend to get
pretty
i guess you could call it their their s
kind of scientists but with words i
always call philosophy
when i describe it to someone who's
going to take a philosophy class i say
it's basically math problems like word
math problems okay so that's basically
what it is so they take
words very seriously and they're very
formal and definitions very seriously
yeah so they all want to get on the same
page so they're not so there is no
confusion
so for ein rand to basically say you can
know everything
and you know and establish ethics from
that i think philosophers
automatically say no now that doesn't
mean i say no
um in fact we even we have at my
university a wonderful business school
and when you walk into the dean
of the business school's office ein rand
is everywhere
so it's so i want to say that not all
academics are anti-iron rand
um and in fact i don't think
philosophers are either
except that they don't teach ein rand
okay so in one
one sense you could say that because
they don't teach her they're being
exclusive in what they teach or very
particular perhaps is another way to put
it
yeah it's hard to know where to place
people like her because um
you know do you put albert camus as a
philosopher so
i guess what's the good term for that
like literary philosophers
or whatever the term is it's annoying to
me that
the academic philosophers get to own the
word philosophy
because like it's just like people who
think deeply about life
is what i think about his philosophy and
like
to me it's like all right so i know
nietzsche is another person that's
probably not
respected in the philosophy circles
because he is
you know full of contradictions full of
uh i love nietzsche
he's just my favorite philosopher oh
really yes i absolutely love nietzsche
so he's definitely you know i i love
people that are full of ideas even if
they're full of contradictions and
nietzsche absolutely
and iran is also that i'm able to um
look past the obvious ego that's there
on the page
and uh the fact that she actually has in
my view a lot of
wrong ideas uh but there's a lot of
interesting tidbits to pick up
and uh the same same goes with nietzsche
and i'm
i'm weirded out by the religious aspect
here
on both the people who like worship iran
and people who completely dismiss her i
i just kind of see it as
oh can we just read a few interesting
things and get inspired by it and move
on
as opposed to no have a dogmatic
is there something you find about her
work that's interesting to you
um or her personality or any of that
oh i think she's fascinating um i don't
dismiss her
um she was a woman who reached a level
of success
with her mind at a time when that was
difficult so
i mean she's definitely um worth looking
at
for for even that reason um but also um
her idea i guess part
of the situation with rand first of all
i think that
um her work is you have to
it's misinterpreted okay and i think
that's the same with nietzsche
like a lot of people think that i mean
in fact
it is the case that nietzsche's writing
before the 20th century so he's got you
know he's
somewhat his rhetoric is
sexist and racist and you know of the
time period
right he was a educated
philosopher of that time period however
um his books are amazing
and nietzsche's philosophy is incredible
and i think that i think that's what
you're
saying about rand too and i agree i mean
i think that
that um we get caught up i mean
likely we should and we should
contextualize these thinkers
in the time period within which they are
we should not forgive
their you know because there were people
during nietzsche's time that
were you know uh feminist and and not
racist and things like that and
you know so but uh each has
merit i mean i would say nietzsche is
and
i you did ask me to talk about some of
the books that made the largest impact
on me
and the nietzsche's gay science is one
of them it's one of the best books
ever in my opinion i do think nietzsche
was uh
i don't know about exactly sexist he
certainly was sexist but
it felt like he didn't get laid much in
his life
no it felt like he was extra sexist
i was like his theories on women are
like all right he's pretty angry
he seems frustrated yeah
like all right calm down buddy the fate
of philosophers
i just ignore everything
you